c'est l'un des dossiers les plus
brûlants la réforme des retraites mise
de côté comme tous les chantiers de
l'exécutif pour cause d'épidémie de kobe
elle est à nouveau dans l'actualité
depuis son arrivée à matignon jean
castex s'est déjà penché dessus à
l'assemblée nationale le 8 juillet
dernier le premier ministre a affiché la
volonté du gouvernement de poursuivre
cette réforme
des propos appuyés par bruno le maire
cette semaine le ministre de l'économie
qui la jugent indispensable je pense
qu'il est nécessaire d'aller au bout de
cette réforme des retraites
on voit bien d'abord qu'il y a un
déficit on voit bien que nous vivons
tous plus longtemps on voit bien que
collectivement il faut que nous
travaillons davantage et que c'est une
condition de redressement de la france
loin de l'avoir enterré le gouvernement
a même planché sur cette réforme pendant
le confinement
c'est ce que révèle une note secrète de
la direction de la sécurité sociale daté
du mois de mai et publié le 12 juillet
par nos confrères du parisien
s'il était considéré que le contexte
politique née de la crise sanitaire
rendait impossible la reprise du projet
de réforme systémique telle quelle cette
note et les fiches ont pour objet
d'expertisé des scénarios de réforme de
retraite alternatif au projet actuel
en tout cinq pistes alternatives sont
développés dans ce document la première
consisterait à appliquer intégralement
la fameuse clause du grand père
la réforme ne concernerait donc que les
nouveaux entrants sur le marché du
travail soit ceux nés en 2004 et après
pour les auteurs de la note
cette piste présente je cite la plus
grande acceptabilité sociale mais
pourrait être perçu comme un recul du
gouvernement
une clause du grand-père intégral qui
présenteraient une plus grande
acceptabilité sociale en période de
crise et résout nombre de difficultés
liées à la transition matière de
conditions d'ouverture et de calculs de
droit en particulier le coût des
compensations financières nécessaires à
son acceptation écrivent les auteurs la
deuxième piste présentés dans le
document est celle d'une retraite à deux
étages soit un régime universel
ce socle commun le premier étage
pourrait prendre la forme d'un système
universel limitait à un plafond ou d'une
généralisation des règles du
régime général à l'ensemble des régimes
de base indique la note est un régime
complémentaire qui pourrait être divisé
en trois privées publiques et non
salariés
si pour les auteurs cette piste
répondrai je cite aux critiques sur
l'uniformisation du système de retraite
au détriment du risque selon les
professions et le profil de carrière
il reste toutefois difficile à mettre en
place autre scénario des mesures
d'économies pour remettre notre système
de retraite à l'équilibré
les auteurs de la note suggère selon le
parisien de relever l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ou encore d'instaurer
un âge minimal à partir duquel un
individu pourra partir à la retraite
sans décote à la clé 15 milliards
d'euros d'économies en 2027
deux autres plans d'actions sont aussi
cités dans le document mais jugé peu
probable un abandon de la réforme au
profit de quelques mesures fortes comme
la disparition des régimes spéciaux ou
encore la réduction du nombre de caisses
et de leurs effectifs
l'exécutif devra donc trancher sur la
façon de remettre en marche la réforme
des retraites
un exercice d'équilibrisme puisque le
gouvernement s'est déjà heurté à
certains partenaires sociaux ces
derniers l'ont exhorté à ne pas rouvrir
ce chantier tout de suite pour donner la
priorité à la relance de l'économie
durement touché par la pandémie de kobe
de 19